un studio de télévision intérieur nuit
dans le studio 2 ans sont assis presque
face à face le metteur en scène de
cinéma jean luc godard un journaliste de
télévision bernard pivot
une cinquantaine de personnes sont
assises dans le studio
l'émission à lyon direct
bernard pivot va poser des questions
c'est son métier
jean luc godard et y répondre ce n'est
pas son métier mais c'est un exercice
dans lequel depuis trente trois ans
qu'il fait des films il excelle
dieu metteur en scène suprême vous
souhaite une bonne émission
merci dieu bonsoir à tous bonsoir jean
luc godard il faut alors dieu pourquoi
bien explications tout à l'heure comme
nous évoquerons le dernier film hélas
pour moi
alors à propos d' explications télérama
cette émission ce tête à tête l'a
présenté ainsi en disant c'est la
rencontre de l'homme qui ne veut rien
expliqué avec celui qui veut tout savoir
vraiment vous ne voulez rien expliqué
lange
je prétends aux savoirs sans savoir
grand chose mais je veux rien expliqué
non mais vous dis enfin si vous aimez
expliqué quand même chose ou pas oui si
ça si ça dure longtemps sur la le temps
me poser
la science a bien tout expliqué je pense
que
le cinéma et
cinématographe et quand il est né avait
une double fonction une fonction de
employant les mots habituels une
fonction de fiction est une fiction
documentaire
et
qui sont très vite mélangés dans l'eure
dans les premiers films de
lumière les le documentaire de langlois
sur lumière à a très bien montré comment
quand il filme un tramway lumière en
fait film est comme
common comme monnaie peignait qu'il
était saoul influence sous cette
influence la et récits et réciproquement
et puis le
documentaire s'est vite perdu je pense
la fonction principale du cinéma est
d'être un document le cinéma est fait
pour penser et sa manière spéciale
d'agrandir les choses de projeter fait
que ça devient spectaculaire et en a
gardé le côté spectaculaire il vous
pensez pas que l'explication retire de
la poésie aux oeuvres d'art
folie j'ai n'importe quel roman plus
proche explique albertine
plus comme dit jean genet quand il a
quand on lui a donné
dans une cour de prison un jour en lui
disant tiens c'est pour toi et on lui a
donné un long des jeunes filles en fleur
et il a lu le premier paragraphe qui
était je crois
je crois que c'est l'arrivée de monsieur
norpois chez le papa et la maman de
marcel proust et la luge de phrases
immense et il s'arrêtait là dial a joué
à l'est de marseille à merveille
ou bien alors j'ai regardé un peu la
presse là
dans le nouvel observateur jacques
drillon écrit que vous êtes l'homme le
plus intelligent qu'on a eu depuis
valéry et l'artiste plus un pur que le
cinéma est offert depuis qu'elles
existent quand il dit un pur évidemment
il place la l'impureté
comme qualité supérieure du cinéma
bernard verley qu'il joue l'un des
principaux rôles de votre film dit dans
l'événement du jeudi parce qu'elle vous
a fréquenté puisqu'il est allé chez vous
en suisse pendant deux jours avant des
bas il dit que vous êtes un homme plongé
dans une recherche éperdue de vérité sur
une planète de plus en plus désertes
et gérard lefort olivier séguret
écrivent dans libération alors là ça se
termine par une question hélas pour moi
est un film irascible mal luné de très
mauvais poil comme si une colère qui
grondait sans jamais pouvoir sourdre on
peut se poser la question jusqu'où
godard tient-il à être aimé jusqu'où
godard qui est il à être mieux
et je vous ai dit quand on s'est vus ça
me le mélange que la télévision fait les
médias depuis un certain moment qui fait
beaucoup de tort je crois à l'humanité
c'est de mélanger la la personnalité là
et la personne si vous voulez alors vous
verrez le jean luc et la personne godard
c'est c'est le nom de mon père c'est pas
mon nom
on m'a appelé jean luc pearson on m'a
pas appelé ou c'est vous qui m'appelait
que faire la maman m'appeler jean-luc
comme elle vous appelez bernard
senon lui et ce nom n'existe pas
non mais le fait qu'on dit godard qui a
t'il être aimé mais j'en sais rien je le
connais pas le ministre de l'intérieur
connaît peut-être godard
moi je le connais je le connais pas je
me faire connaître
peut-être comme ça mais ça fausse assez
d'accentuer ce côté là non je trouve non
mais la question est celle ci est ce que
vous ne faites pas tout pour ne pas être
aimée
non je crois eu
une cher ami à moi me dit
ton gros problème c'est que tu ne t'aime
pas
et je lui dis alors je lui dis
expliquons-nous contraire
expliquons-nous l'explication que ça
fait déjà vingt ans que ça fait que ça
dure donc expliquons-nous j'ai
l'impression
je vois ce que tu veux dire et en même
temps l'impression je n'aime que moi mal
odilon extérieurement et intérieurement
certainement il ya quelque chose c'est
vrai que jeune adolescent je me souviens
d'une phrase de saint-just qui m'a
subjugué qui disait je méprise la
poussière dont je suis fait qu'ils vous
parlent en pleine assemblée constituante
remarquez ça serait pas mal qui
d'entendre rocard dix ans
mais c'est une phrase qui met ça cesse
et l'adolescence qui je trouve est
magnifique c'est comme ça maintenant je
la comprend dix ans effectivement il ya
quelque chose de moi que je il ya
quelque chose peut-être je ne m'aime pas
et je ne peux me l'expliquer qu'en dix
ans mais
ai-je eu raison de vouloir revenir sur
cette terre quand on m'a appelé
votre avis ainsi tous les enfants
si tout va les mamans le savent bien les
enfants
fayard il ya un appel et un désir de
l'enfant pour n'être rien désir des
parents qui laissent et puis
il ya le rencontre si l'enfant ne
désirait pas venir il ne vient pas
ce désir fonctionner chez vous eh ben je
me demande
je me demandais je pense que les les
films qui sont tels qu'ils sont faits
par l'accueil qui enregistre qui
prennent le temps de regarder cet
enregistrement comme les scientifiques
c'est très scientifique ensuite de le
projeter une manière différente et les
scientifiques en grand deux pour que
plusieurs personnes peuvent les voir
pour qu'il ya une certaine justice et
démocratie qu'un tribunal le
bon choix un peu plus que j'allais mer
bon non c'était sur vous parce que vous
dites que vous ne bon une partie de vous
pour le mans qui refuse d'être aimé mais
cette façon parler de
ces nouvelles jules goda vous donnez
l'impression moment où j'ai été abusée
et j'ai été abusé quand j'étais jeune en
cinéma n'ont pas puisque quand on fait
des films on a 30 ans fait son premier
film on dit qu'on est un jeune cinéaste
alors que souvent des départs en sont
déjà des vieux adultes à cet âge
donc quand j'étais jeune j'ai été abusé
par sa part l'intérêt comprenait à à moi
et que
je croyais qu'on s'intéressait à
l'oeuvre est faible quand même une
différence je ne suis que le serviteur
de mon oeuvre
alors je veux bien être interrogé en
tant que serviteur ma personnalité de
serviteurs on peut l'appeler godard
comme
etc mais
non mais c'est à dire vous donnez
l'impression comme ça d'être aujourd'hui
quelqu'un de un peu de retrancher dans
sa bibliothèque dans sa cinémathèque qui
considère qu'au fond que la seule
aventure qui mérite d'être vécue
aujourd'hui celle aventures de l'art est
d'ailleurs thierry jousse dans les
cahiers du cinéma qui vous interpellent
est dit vous avez l'air d'être réfugiés
exilés en vous même
si une part de vrai ou c'est
complètement faux
mais d'abord je suis fier d'être exilé
puisque les trois quarts
des gens que j'aime que ce soit les
les palestiniens qui rentre d'exil
d'autres choses les prisonniers
ça je ne je ne vois pas des cons je me
souviens de quelque chose que disait
virginia woolf sur écrire elle disait à
écrire c
c voire des pales disait des mots des
phrases ou des choses loin loin et puis
entre eux et vous il ya un gouffre
terrible et il faut les faire traverser
ce gouffre où vous traversez ce gouffre
écrire et en devient
enfin entré comme l'a finie aussi tous
ne finisse pas comme ça mais dont il ya
quelque chose oui nous a nourris crois
pas malheur bibliothèque tout ça mais
c'est pas vrai donc c'est pas vrai mais
ça c'est les journalistes on peut pas
leur demander de on peut plus leur
demander d'écrire peut-être du temps de
rochefort mais dans melrose forme
qu'aujourd'hui un peu plus leur demander
il écrit que sache pourquoi pour exister
il écrit bhl nous les gens ça n'a pas
c'est très différent de ce qu'on était à
l'époque de la nouvelle jamais j'aurais
crise à necker mais jamais j'aurais dit
becker et
j'ai pas quelque chose ou ophuls enfin
retrouvant la fera jamais
pourquoi vous auriez pas osé ou pas ce
que c'est mais ça m'intéressait pas
verser dans ce qui m'intéresse c'est
comment ils rataient nos pas comment ils
rataient
montparnasse 19 mais comment était raté
mon par la 19è combien ce ratage était
absolument magnifique par rapport à tout
le cinéma français de l'époque
clairement fichait alors peut-être un
événement à l'époque mais
quand même j'ai eu pas mal de
déclarations de vous lassez pas des
mails devraient se laisser prendre au
piège ou est-ce qu'on est vain et
onéreux et puis j'adore parler pour ne
rien dire ah bon
mais n'en fait goûter j'ai vu tellement
déclarations de vous par exemple
tournant autour du succès on a
l'impression quand même alors sauf
erreur énorme que vous considérez
presque le succès est comment dire
péjoratif ou ou presque malsain d'une
certaine manière oui d'une certaine
manière oui j'ai eu la chance d'avoir
une et encore ça doit pas être vrai mais
mon souci est d'avoir un souvenir
d'existence renault 21 espèces de romans
avec une grande famille beaucoup de gens
de l'argent de la discipline
et puis après bon
et puis après quand j'ai commencé à
avoir eu la chance de commencer après
les années de misère habituels ou
jeunes balzacien qui voulait conquérir
paris j'ai eu par hasard d'avoir un
succès le coup quel jeu me fait et tout
de suite après un énorme échec
et puis après bon ben
ça je trouve ça ça équilibre car
effectivement c'est très difficile pour
un on le voit que les joueurs de tennis
par exemple j'aime bien ou des choses
j'aime beaucoup pioline par exemple
parce qu'il reste ce qui lui arrive je
suis ravi ce n'est pas par la fédération
française de tennis forgé comme ça c'est
très bien il s'en est fait il fait son
trou et parce qu'il est dans la marge du
tennis oui j'aime la marge dans les
cahiers j'aime la marche parce que dans
les marges on met des notes et
les professeurs ou si il les met dans la
mare 20 oui mais pioline c'est vrai
qu'il est dans la marge par rapport à la
fédération il joue divinement bien non
après j'aime pas son jeu j'ai moins son
jeu
oui mais c'est le succès lui lui c'est
le succès aujourd'hui et en demi-finales
de flushing line mais voyez il ya quand
même quelque chose qui n'existe pas
quand vous voyez tous les joueurs de
tennis qui font quand ils gagnent
maintenant qu'ils se croient obligés de
faire
mais chaque point non mais c'est très
différent l'eifel les femmes le font
très peu ils font des femmes très peu
alors serré le poing comme ça pour soi
c'est autre chose faire ça sept autres
c'était autre chose aussi ce médication
faire ça et on en vient à ce que je me
souviens dans toujours pour rester au
tennis l'entraîneur georges goven il
disait aux malheureux qui se faisait
écrabouillé par ce très bon krishnan the
gentleman indien ou inde où il lui
disait tu le mec
il faut pas s'étonner sarajevo si si
même au tennis payer les millions qui
sont millions il ya cinq caisses qui a
besoin or ça c'est la mélangent
les excès de personnalité c'est le nom
et c'est pas la nommer luc godard ça ce
sont les excès du succès il ya des
succès de bon aloi qui sont ces preuves
il l'être aujourd'hui je ne crois pas
alors c'est curieux parce qu'on l'a pas
s'aperçoit que vous avez pas tellement
changé je n'ai pas changé d'avis là
dessus là vous retrouvez ce que vous
déclariez à françois chalais à cannes en
1968 il ya donc 33 ans à bout de souffle
venait d'être un succès considérable et
vous apprêtiez à tourner votre second
film s'intitule le petit soda bien on va
le voir c'était déjà godard tel qu'il
est aujourd'hui
ce qui me surprend pas lempaut par
rapport dans mon second fils par rapport
au premier c'est que
enfin je suis déjà plus fatigué
fatigué je veux dire
déjà beaucoup de choses que
c'est difficile à dire c'est pas comment
dire je veux dire j'ai l'impression
d'aimer moins de cinéma que qu'il ya un
an uniquement parce que j'ai fait un
film et que ce film a plu est comme ça
alors je souhaite que mon second
déplaise énormément et que ça me donne
envie de faire du cinéma de nouveau
parce que c'est ça c'est ça l'esprit de
contradiction dont je vous parlais je
voulais la légende font totalement
confiance alors
j'espère que je vais les décevoir comme
ça ils font plus confiance et et j'ai
mieux travaillé que des gens qui me
contre lequel il faut lutter je n'ai pas
changé non pas vraiment vous signez là
pas vraiment quoiqu'elle une expression
dont canton de vaud qui est être déçus
en bien
j'aimerais décevoir les gens bien là je
la corrigerai un peu trop déçu en bien
c'est pas mal
mais enfin bon mais vous êtes quand même
qu'un parent cinéma parce que la plupart
décidé à part c'est que je gagne ma vie
avec des films qui ne marche pas alors
ça c'est très simple comment faites-vous
ben je sais pas je vous le demande
noveski là c'est incroyable parce que eh
ben oui c'est que d'habitude des
collègues viennent pas d'argent et de
cinéma on est sanctionné immédiatement
on peut plus faire de films c'est fini
on y arrive
vous et non mais pas comme moi
quelle est votre recette mais j'en ai
pas et si vous dites je fais des films
qui marchent j'aime j'aime faire de
j'aime faire du cinéma oui mais vous
avez toujours les moyens jean marie
straub et danièle aime aussi il a
beaucoup plus de mal que moi il fait des
films souvent mieux que les miens
jambes mais vous pensez pas aussi vous
avez atteint un niveau de célébrité oui
mais c'est sa vérité c'est que je
représente quelque chose on n'est que
des images je pense qu'on est des
humains des modèles des images d'image
oui mais saumur voumard les non pas des
photos pas des fruits géographie on
représente on représente quelque chose
donc à des moments
et puis là depuis la mort de françois la
france aux jo anne marie m'a mise il m'a
dit qui est votre compagne on est une
banque est l'associé de relogement
nous sommes deux compagnons où l'enjeu
commun du terme et
et qui hélas
la gérante de la petite société de
cinéma que violent que nous possédons et
nous possédons en particulier le fait
d'être franco suisse et de naviguer
mais c'est grâce à d'autres à cette
image de vous pour reprendre votre terme
nous le disait par rapport à françois
truffaut
maintenant que les morts que maintenant
qu'il est mort
vous allez être privés de protection
il vous protégera plus puisque c'était
le seul de la nouvelle vague qui était
qui avait été acceptée et qui avait
cherché à rejoindre ce qu'on peut dire
entre guillemets l'establishment
en quoi il vous protège plus
ben nous protégeait parce que ils
n'osaient pas attaquer le à travers lui
qui était comme à mon avis plus
conventionnel que d'autres mais ils
n'osaient pas là ils n'oseraient pas
attaquer
ils n'osaient pas attaquer de front un
certain genre de film ou d'art ou de
résistance artistique au sens où le lift
robecq maintenance
maintenant ils oseraient ça m'étonne de
plus en plus que j'arrive mais je crois
que ça c'est l'amitié de deux ou trois
personnes ou si et ça existe qui fait
qu'on peut continuer de même que comment
est ce que je m'excuse de prendre de
grands exemples c'est pas pour me
comparer à eux sinon dans la démarche
quand
ambroise vollard ou durand ruel a à
protéger certains ou d'un moment pizarro
je crois pas courber passe nous daumier
passe dans la rue et courbe était là il
passe devant la maison de pizarro il
avait rien et demande un peu d'argent et
pizarro lui redonne puis finalement il
lui donne la maison
c'est magnifique
vous pensez pas quand même permis à
votre image que après tout si deux à
dieu ne plaise demain vous décidiez et
bien vous feriez toute la presse du
monde entier dirais c'est l'un des plus
grands cinéastes du xxème siècle qui
vient de mourir c'est évident vous le
savez donc fatalement ce bénéfice un peu
les films rapport à ben voilà la
différence non pas les gens qui vont
écrire qu'ils écriront sauve à ce moment
là ils ont vu vos films et les ont aimés
ils les connaissent bien très peu mais
c'est très peu mais ça c'est votre
pessimisme des fonds si les normes sepa
s'immisça mais si les gens vivent au
film il les aime bien des numéro des
cahiers du cinéma que j'ai lu là cette
semaine qui est paru il ya trois ans un
petit peu non je suis en réseau les
trois quarts nous n'ont depuis peu
importe qu'un non je dis simplement il
ya peut-être quelque chose en moi je
n'aime pas ce que je suis pas
véritablement comme ça s'il faut mais
c'est gênant d'être de parler de soi
comme ça devant devant de monde ça ne se
fait pas ça ne se fait pas un comme ça
moi je pense que la caméra est proche du
taux scop microscope télescope on
examine les maladies et de la bonne
santé oms on ne se fait pas
alors on en cherche un peu pour avoir du
succès et moi je suis très très gêné
parce qu'effectivement on doit se servir
du nom aujourd'hui
pour avoir une
je dois me servir encore de mon nom
parce que les gens
je dois représenter peut-être une façon
de croire à ce qui s'est appelé le
cinématographe qui a
trait changé et que je représente en
corse ou encore ça plutôt que des films
et les films n'ont pas d'importance
qu'une croyants de même pas pourquoi les
gens vont voir
font la queue ch pour voir
rogge des choses comme ça c'est qu'il
doit y avoir
il doit y avoir une idée qu'il a vu des
choses qui ont deux manières de voir que
eux ne peuvent plus voir même leur
propre vie ou leur propre problème donc
voilà alors parlons de votre film hélas
pour moi
vous avez repris 2 vous avez repris
cette légende cette mythologie
c'est-à-dire de d'amphitryon avait fait
amphitryon part pour la guerre à ce
moment-là ce sous jupiter comme on veut
je jupiter prend là la forme du du mari
qui est parti et bien séduire la femme
qui reste et qui évidemment le confond
avec avec l'autre pourquoi alors ce
thème a été traité par molière entre
autres par parole giraudoux et d'autres
et pourquoi l'avez-vous reprise
mythe mais ça je ne sais pas je ne sais
pas non non puisque ça se fait pas enfin
là je crois que j'ai assez dans la marge
même par rapport à l'autre je ne fais
pas le film ne s'est pas fait comme ça
un soir gérard depardieu m'a dit
il faudrait faire quelque chose ensemble
puis on est resté à bavarder un pas dire
grand chose lui reste parce qu'on a pas
grand chose à se dire mais il y avait un
climat de
paix comme qu'on ait un coût d'un un air
de jazz ou un truc comme ça un climat de
confiance ou d'amitié moi je l'avais
admirer dans un ou deux films et je lui
avais dit tout en pensant que c'était
soit trop tôt soit trop tard pour moi
pour faire un film avec lui au stade
et puis après
il a dû le dire à des gens qui ont lu le
dire à d'autres j'en ai un ami
producteur m'a dit
jupiter à ce moment là le contrat est
signé on doit faire un film tel jour à
telle heure le direct commence at elle
ajouté alors il faut bien écrire quelque
chose donner une idée mais je vous
assure que je crois que tous mes films
j'ai fait
non mais pourquoi voulez-vous loi condé
s'est fait comme ça mais tous tous tous
j'espère arriver une fois à faire ce que
fait marie miéville ce que fait trop
beau que même si puis le merde
faire un
normalement oui écrire
penser ensuite composer mettre en place
et faire le mieux possible
jamais j'ai pu faire ça mais d'une
certaine manière
je suis en direct
tout le temps et un moment donné je me
souviens d'une phrase de raymond
chandler dans son journal
et qui disait quand on écrit un livre on
ne fait que ça si on allume une
cigarette
ça fait partie de l'écriture si on ne
fait rien toute la journée comme saoulé
un tel endroit comme lui faisait c'est
ça écrire et que donc moi je le fais
tout le temps et puis un moment les
circonstances font que ça doivent
concrétiser socialement et j'essaye d'en
tirer parti mais je suis très proche de
ma propre vie comme ça
mais toujours pas expliqué comment
jupiter intervient dans votre couple
avec depardieu au nom du conseil le g2
lire critères on pense pas à lui comme
ça craque un jupiter salut c'est pas
vrai nom alors forcément ce qu'on a fait
avant ce qu'on veut enfin j'ai fait
nouvelle 20 peut-être une idée de domme
double plus cette histoire de
de trinité de trois personnes pas au
sens divin au sens de triangles ou 6 ou
du théorème de thalès ou des choses
d'euclide qui sont des figures et je
travaille aussi à faire des histoires du
cinéma un seuil est de savoir dans le
film que je voulais montrer sur la
russie j'ai trouvé tout à fait par
hasard
comment été trouvée le principe
mécanique physique de la projection
cinématographique et je vous le dis dans
le livre que je vous ai offert la wii
alors dont les visages contrairement à
ce que je pense
si on est une figure on a l'approprient
il ya une propriété les figures ont une
propriété mais encore faut-il être une
figure pas seulement avoir une figure un
visage
d'être projeté alors les gens les plus
simples le le papa à une figue est une
figure pour ses enfants ou pour sa femme
en tant que c'est pas c'est pas son
visage qui peut être profiter c'est sa
figure de père ou des choses ça c'est le
cinéma alors je réfléchi à ça et puis à
des moments donc je pense à peut-être à
dieu ou un truc comme ça et puis cherche
un canevas parce que là j'ai fait pas le
génie de fellow d'un autre et cherche un
canevas et puis j'ai lu ce que j'ai vu
cette histoire qui traînait mais je m'en
souviens plus comment
comment ça c'est fait ça s'est fait
lentement et ses parties de la musique
c'est parti de la musique ou un ami
éditeur allemand et ça se passe comme ça
depuis cet ami éditeur m'envoie des
musiques qui qu'il ait dit ses des
musiques assez marginal cerveau parts et
keith jarrett
sismondi cd mais des musiques quand je
les entends j'ai envie de voir des
choses mais je ne sais pas quoi et ça me
sert un peu de canevas là dessus et là
c'est une musique david darling j'avais
déjà écouté où il y avait simplement
trois mouvements alors on y
réfléchissant maintenant je me dis que
ces trois mouvements m'ont amené à une
idée de la jupiter l'e3 le couple le
coin le vieux souk rio le vieux triangle
étrillant alors d'ailleurs mais dieu
d'ailleurs davos ne s'empare pas
seulement de la créature d'une femme il
s'empare aussi de phrase magnifique
d'écrivains qui sait on peut même dire
que dieu a toujours une citation dans la
bouche d'un autre film mais c'est les
écrivains qui sont magnifiques c'est un
jeu wii mais dieu les aime tellement ses
dires mais ni modère les aime tellement
qu'il est si l'abondance il n'existe pas
il est il les transmet
je fais le même métier vous
oui albert cohen qui était votre voisin
je ne la genève disait de lui que
jupiter et ou the c'était pas du tout un
duo intéressant parce qu'il pensait qu'à
une chose a accouché avec les créatures
et il disait au fond le seul duo
intéressant c'est le dieu judéo chrétien
parce que lui il a une morale alors que
alors que the subs hier ils n'ont
absolument aucune morale est ce que vous
en pensez
vous préférez les dieux autrement dit
avec morales ou sans morale
[Musique]
soit pas de grosses différences entre
les faux-pas gros différentes puis je
m'y connais pas beaucoup et pourtant si
quand même là c'est vrai que c'est
différent il ya une grosse différence
entre le le christ et et rome et le
vatican
ayem volume mais le reste je ne sais pas
bon on a l'impression quand même que
dans ce film même s'il est plein de
clins d'oeil de l'impression quand même
que vous vous êtes taraudé par une sorte
comment dirais-je de métaphysique
genevoise et mais vous allez me dire
mais pas du tout le mois je raconte une
histoire pas plus non il n'y a pas de
métaphysique et dénis genevoise ni
protestante n'ai
rien fait autre chose la métaphysique
le film peut en faire il doit il doit en
faire mais si ça peut pas
ça peut pas se parler comme ça sur un
plateau télé vision non pas par une
métaphysique son atelier une vision
on peut mais il faudrait que la
télévision sur autre chose que ce qui
est bon mais c'est l'occasion à
vancouver non non non faut pas ça fait
pas comme ça non
votre film vous avez vous l'avait
présenté en avant-première dans le gère
c'est d'ailleurs le film pas retenu a
été représentée hu a été accueilli et
beaucoup de ferveur beaucoup de passion
par les gens c'est souvent des gens très
simples endroit qui est pire le message
on m'a dit que la question qui revenait
le plus souvent c'était une question sur
la bande son les gens disaient comment
pourquoi mettez-vous en superposition
plusieurs sont plusieurs paroles au
risque de ne pas être compris qu'est ce
que vous leur répondre en loge
maintenant après trente ans de cinéma je
connais assez bon mon travail pour quand
quand je veux faire entendre quelque
chose elle faire comprendre le faire
entendre ce qui a en un son assez de
plus amples très très uniforme
aujourd'hui beaucoup plus uniforme car
avant l'un
qu'avant la deuxième guerre mondiale et
mêmes même après dans l'est dans les
films la technique vous fait croire qu à
beaucoup de choses mais on utilise pas
vraiment moins - même que la moins même
que la musique là je dirai ce qui est
c'est difficile effectivement quand vous
avez tout à coup une phrase comme
de robes robert musil un de robert musil
nous ne sommes pas capables de nous
libérer nous mêmes cela ne fait aucun
doute et nous appelons sa démocratie et
puis deux secondes après vous avez
phrase de françoise dolto l'ombre de
dieu tout homme ne l'at-il pas pour une
femme qui aime son homme
il faut du temps pour apprécier la
comprendre la revendiquer la porter à
quelqu'un ouvre donc la jemaye comme ça
mais ça c'est les conditions et la
sociale du cinéma parce qu'on ne me
donne pas une heure
régulièrement pour étudier cette phrase
de dolto
difficile
là vous êtes c'est plus qu'une marge va
vous demander d'être plus que la marge
vous êtes dehors des seins dehors du
cahier là mais oui chacun mais on vit
comme on peut hein mais alors en même
temps ce qui surprend dans votre film
c'est que que ce soit dans le générique
du début d'un générique de fin il n'ya
pas votre nom c'est godard n'apparaît
pas dans le film hélas pour moi pourquoi
parce que il faut que j'arrive
maintenant à faire quand même oublier un
peu mon nom qui me fait du tort car il
s'adresse pas à la à la personne et de
voir des affiches comme ça mon jeu je me
suis pas fâché que le distributeur du
film qui est un qui est un brave homme
en plus c'était pas producteur de suivre
simplement metteur en scène donc
un certain devoir et peu de et peu de
peu de droit pourquoi qu'est ce qui vous
déplaît dans cette affiche
non même pas des noms aussi gros que ça
on n'est pas à moi je demande toujours
de mon nom soit mais en plus petit et si
possible un moment
aujourd'hui il ya trop de trous de non
j'aimerais qu'il y est le film
effectivement j'aimerais que moi ça
n'empêcherait pas ça ça ne me gêne pas
d'être forcé de parler du du film et non
pas qu'est ce qu'il a fait je vois que
ça me gêne beaucoup quand j'entends une
belle musique ou une musique et menace
de devoir dire de qui est ce ça ne
m'aide absolument pas pour comprendre
pour aimer pour apprécier la musique ça
va me permettre de la retrouver comme un
policier qui est celui là vos papiers
non ça
une affiche dans la rue il faut bien que
les gens apprennent que hélas pour moi
c'est un film de godard et depardieu
mais non mais ça me fait du tort aux
autres jours je joue au tennis à 15 un
jeune qui joue avec moi il m'a dire ah
bon loll vendredi vous allez à vienne et
voulait dire venise mais il savait même
pas qu'elle 1 quel intérêt je vous
l'avais battue n'ont certainement pas il
sait lui avait battu phillies non
non mais
ça fait de la peine et ça me fait du mal
aujourd'hui ça me fait du mal j'en ai
trop mais sur ce responsable le pape a
appelé l'inde pour moi mais j'essaye
j'aimerais arriver effectivement
longtemps que je m'aime bien là un
vaniteux ou orgueilleux j'aimerais
arriver à faire un film dont les gens
que les genres est moins précis ou en
tout cas une partie qui dit c'est beau
ça renouvelle ses quelque chose et qu'il
ne savait et sous un faux nom
oui c'est fermé gary avait réussi on est
bien on peut comprendre on peut
comprendre on peut comprendre hélas ou
pas de nom oui mais là les gens qui vont
dans la salle toute façon sauf
les leaders de l'accord ou énorme c'est
pas très intéressant et la télévision et
les médias ont tordu beaucoup ça ils
font énormément de mal on le voit on le
voit sur le sport ou truc on voit même
avec ceux ce malheureux bernard tapie
aujourd'hui salue le bon il l'a bien
cherché mais
il ya qu'il est pas entièrement
responsable non plus
tu comprends pas
maintenant quand on ne vit que de nom
c'est pas le nom et il ne s'agit pas que
de nom vous êtes à l'opposé d'un fable
est évident donc je vois pas pourquoi
aller jusqu'au bout et en retirer votre
nom du film on a l'impression que sinon
il n'est pas près d'être non voulait
plus dans nos maigres moyens partir dans
les affiches plaît mais pourquoi vous
voulez pas disparaître quand même
l'impression qu'une sorte de volonté de
comme ça que vous effacez nommé pour
cela pour un autre challenge
si normalement c'est pas ça sous la dent
n'avait pas bien duras à bout de souffle
n'était pas plus cyniques suis là à
l'époque est pas bon non plus au
générique je n'y pensais même pas je ne
savais pas que ça se faisait mais je
vous assure du naïveté mais non blues ne
fait pas que ça se faisait
automatiquement à rue on est bien vu
qu'hitchcock le faisait ou que steven je
le faisais et on dirait on disait du res
ce sont eux les auteurs du crime
non mais parlons d'autre chose mais moi
ce que je lis un livre vous aimeriez
qu'il n'y ait pas de loi ne ferait pas
nommer un truc étonnant dans les livres
c'est je le voyais avec une une femme
que j'ai connue autrefois mais c'est
tous pareils on voit anne wiazemsky le
petit navire aux copains et puis en
dessous il ya une autre bande où on
remet en plus gros anne wiazemsky alors
ça vous qu'il ya dedans dans la
profession pourquoi pas parce que c'est
pour la satire le renvoi de plus loin
vous êtes doué donc on voit on dit tiens
c'est à dire c'est ce qui m'est bien
encore il ya quelque chose de plus
l'étonnante chez moi c'est que y'a scène
ce qui est quand même elle est un peu
connue elle a non laisser passez
ouvriers non mais vous voyez aujourd'hui
non les premiers romans des gens
totalement inconnu et alors que
tellement inconnu il ya marqué du
schnokeloch vous de ces métiers du chef
tu sais même pas qu'il est publié alors
dans trois ans le mettra trois fois oui
je sais pas peut-être mais alors quand
même alors dit vous vous effacez comme
ça il ya cette volonté de cette humilité
mais en même temps vous êtes aujourd'hui
vous étiez à venise votre film était en
compétition alors vous qu'est ce que
vous foutez dans une compétition à venir
vous qui êtes un as in est assez laid
mais qu'est ce que vous faites briguer
des lauriers à venise mais c'est
incroyable non alors large des réponses
je dirais pas ça d'abord c'est pas moi
et personne ne voulait y aller pour ce
film bombe allait quasiment tout seul
quasiment un film va pas tout seul c'est
le co producteur suisse qui voulait y
aller ah bon bon non mais je me souviens
que allemagne allemagne 9 0 qui est un
film qui avait été produit par cet opus
de maison qui est un film de télévision
donc enfin en régime en t comme un film
de télévision et moi ça me faisait du
mal lui qui ne soit pas considérée comme
un film dit de cinéma et j'avais demandé
à être en compétition
à faire une course commun ou à voir une
wild card comme on lit au tennis pour
pouvoir
être compétitif a qu'à l'époque et
philippe garrel ou chantal akerman ou
des choses comme ça sont là je me
sentais
nord normal si vous voulez voilà c'est
tout
si demain demain ou après demain vous
avez lion d'or jamais à leur arc femmes
mais pas quatre cantons s'inscrire qu'on
s'est trompé dit son tennis et pour
gagner donc si vous avez annoncé pour
jouer
kelly aussi non
après avoir joué oui
mais cet autre position non non il ya
quelque chose qui va qui va pas du tout
là mais envoyer une lettre très amical
il ya trois-quatre jours me disais je
voudrais pas rester comme charpak assis
pendant toute l'émission
ben oui mais c'est parti comme ça aussi
mais si on peut se lever souris c'est
difficile au nom vous est difficile il
faudrait que ça soit un jury
vous voulez vous les voyez l'avocat non
non non et puis que je doive plaider ma
cause et les convaincre fermé le contre
interrogatoire comme dans les affaires
environnement
sujet de joux de les juger où en est le
cinéma aujourd'hui qu'est la santé du
cinéma le cinéma va t'il bien qu'est-ce
qui se passe vous savez bien qu'il y en
a plus
je n'ai même pas comment il y en a plus
non il ya d un plus il ya des îlots en
même temps il ya presque comme ça mais
il n'y a plus d'un
[Musique]
d'ailleurs pour nous le cinéma était
dollar et 1 la nouvelle vague est un art
très particulier qui était alors aux
accusé de mépriser le public ce qu'on
respecte et que c'est qu'il était
populaire et qui n'avait pas besoin il
n'avait pas besoin d'être van gogh il
n'est pas besoin d'être beethoven il
donne sigl n'a pas besoin d'être b tome
ça suffit d'être d'une cigale ou becker
n'a pas besoin d'elle jean sébastien
bach ça suffit et pourtant il appartient
au même pays de l'armée d'une façon tout
à fait différente c'est ce qui nous a
[Musique]
c'est ce qui nous a séduits certainement
dans les enfants jouent la russie est un
film inédit d'où vous dites fait
répondre ceci mais mon pauvre monsieur
le cinéma est mort depuis belle lurette
nous avons conduit méliès 3ème usine
stein au suicide la tirade termine ainsi
et nous faisons reconstruire aux
chouettes par steven spielberg c'est
vrai c'est vrai il a fait reconstruire
offrir pour tourner un film le cinéma
c'est un drôle de pays l'amérique durée
parce qu'il ya personne autant que nous
qui est
mais autant ce qu'on appelle
le cinéma dit américain mais même ce mot
américain le disais à des
journalistes à venise c'est quand même
c'est le seul pays qui n'a pas dans les
habitants n'ont pas non c'est quand même
on les appelle les américains mais les
américains c'est aussi bien les
argentins que les mexicains et comme ça
les etats-unis n'ont pas non
mais ils restent ancrées si demain je
pense que leur puissance vient de là
puisqu'ils n'ont ils n'ont pas été
appelés
vous allez à deauville des fois par
steve actuellement ils sont plusieurs
centaines aujourd'hui à deauville
plusieurs milliers à filtrer le cinéma
américain mais je ne comprends pas
pourquoi ce
on adore tout ce qui vient de de ce pays
dont les habitants n'ont pas non
je vais jouer je voulais dit l'autre
jour à harold je croirais à l'europe le
jour où cet honorable maison passera à
20 heures ou à 22h régulièrement pas
seulement des mauvais films américains
mais aussi des mauvais films turcs des
mauvais films suédois des fnb rement etc
alors ça n'arrive pas qu'avons nous
parce que le public allait faire un
mauvais film américain a beau film
birman et pourquoi pourquoi parce que
j'en sais rien mais ce qui est assez des
sondages qui doivent le dire
le dit matt
l'impression mais comment expliquer
vélos décorés respect qu'il voue qui les
milliers de personnes réunies à
deauville actuellement qui fait le
cinéma américain on voit bien qu'ils
préfèrent ben oui on peut chercher avec
lacan et freud pourquoi on est malade ou
pour qu'on est bien portant
pourquoi dans un ascenseur on est mieux
une musique américaine qu'une musique du
rck
si la science et le cinéma ben
je sais pas mais moi je peux répondre si
on me donne le temps de l'étudier
bons pour y faire un film là-dessus car
tout à fait tout à fait alors à propos
de cinéma américain voici un extrait de
vos histoires de cinéma qui était
merveilleux film de de montage qui est
une sorte de méditation historique et
poétique sur le cinéma
cinémas américains qui voient dans le
dos oui comme collaborent siegfried oui
c'est notre époque c'est notre époque
c'est notre époque écrit l'hymne
américain
ussel la fondation barnes tôt fondation
hda n'irai pas vous irez voir leur
endettement pas pourquoi il ya les
merveilleux tableau 1
la fondation barnes au musée d'orsay
n'irai pas pourquoi d'abord il ya trop
de monde
ensuite si je pense que si le ministre
de la culture actuelle était je pense
qu'ils s'honorerait de saisir les
tableaux de les racheter pour le prix
que barnes
impayés 20 mm 20 mille francs de
l'époque ce qui ce qui est pas mal pour
un renoir comme ça et de les exposer les
faire circuler ça j'irais les voir oui
je me souviens la la la dame du quai
d'orsay vous avez interviewé là comme ça
elle était jeune et pas elle jouissait
vraiment oui parce que l dirinon elle
jouissait vraiment en disant on ne les
verra plus on va aller voir une fois on
les verra plus vais y retourner en
prison tout de suite
[Rires]
ben oui mais ça fait rire bah
oui mais non pas prises en tout de suite
mais si à ça dans un domaine qui est
paisible
cinéma peinture exposition quai d'orsay
forcément il ya une telle injustice par
rapport à ce qu'il fait là une telle
disproportion dans la balance de la
justice
que appreils à sarajevo le sida ou tout
ça c'est clair comment
on ne peut pas il ya des règles il ya
des règles on vit dans un monde physique
qui obéit encore en ce qui concerne la
terre à la bonne vieille loi de
lavoisier monsieur charpak qu on ne
contredira pas ça à partir du moment où
une directrice d'un musée français
d'état et dieu sait si on fait des
belles choses en france comme ça dit
c'est formidable on va plus les voir
dont le disais plus tôt c'est formidable
de les voir aujourd'hui parce que
malheureusement et ils vont tourner les
canadiens l'acca l'égard des par les
rendre elle peut pas à si elle peut
comment elle peut mais les hommes et les
femmes peuvent faire
la résistance s use belling états unis
je voyais un moment donné on a dit on
peut pas résister aux allemands et de
gaulle il est allé chez les anglais dieu
sait s'ils les aimait pas les anglais
donc vous êtes d'accord pour qu'on
engage une épreuve de force des états
unis pour qu'on garde les tableaux de la
fondation bardot mescudi dit pourquoi
pas moi a priori c'est une idée à
creuser c'est pas y'a pas d'idées mais
y'a pas les italiens aussi qui vont
venir nous voir reprendre absolument
toute la peinture italienne qu'il se
trouve au lourd et ben ça fera des
discussions plus intéressante
très bien bon est ce que vous regardez
est ce que vous regardez des chaînes
télévision qui diffuse en permanence des
clips musicaux
est ce que ça vous est arrivé de
regarder quand même de voir je regarde
très peu la télé bien ce que c'est
qu'avec des clips musicaux et là comment
vous trouvez ça
bon ben voilà l'explication dans la
présence journaux qu'est-ce que vous
visez vous êtes un lecteur de journaux
sûrement beaucoup qu'est ce que vous
lisez de préférence quelles sont les
pages les rubriques
dans le monde dit d'abord la colonne la
colonne des changes puisque levée dans
un pays hors de la france regarde
combien a joué sept bulletins étrangers
n'ont qu'à colonne des changes elle
change de change le show à bout de champ
bah oui mais moi je viens suisse avec
des francs français
et quand je suis parti enfin je vis plus
en suisse quand je suis parti un
français valait 2 francs il en vaut 4
aujourd'hui c'est à dire que quand je
suis parti avec ça et maintenant il ya
plus que ça mais j'ai bu quand même
vous ne pouvez plus voir ce que vous
avez vu oui mais j'ai moins soif puisque
fait but
elle essayait d'expliquer sa halle
inspecteurs du fisc qui alors à y croire
à une manigance oui donc si je reviens
vous voulez vous après je lis les plus
tôt l'économie à l'économie plutôt les
colloques les rubriques économique et
financière oui oui mais ça ça vient
alors effectivement du fait que vous
avez un pied sur le franc suisse et un
pied sur le frein française non c'est
dans le cinéma un pied dans l'argent et
un pied dans l'art sans arrêt
et que et aidants et dans tout le
la manière dont fonctionne le cinéma
c'est un j'ai essayé de vendre l'idée
aux ministères la culture et à beaucoup
de choses c'est insiste ce qu'on appelle
un système expert en sciences ou en
économie c'est à dire des modèles de
systèmes qui vous donne des idées mais
là il est un il est à la fois improviser
en direct c'est un système expert en
direct ou à la fois les gens et ce
qu'ils font dans le cinéma c'est des
petites sociétés très vite comme des
sociétés de
mon étudiant en biologie ou en
mathématiques et si on l'étudié on
verrait bon verrait beaucoup de on
verrait beaucoup beaucoup de choses sous
une forme imagée qu'il faudrait
retraduire le tort de la science et que
toujours elle parle un langage qui date
d'il ya deux sens il ya 200 ans mais
maisenberg weishanhu il écrit des
équations que lui seul connaît et puis
quand il fait un livre il écrit dans le
langage de zola
d'où la difficulté la science qui fait
des belles découvertes souvent un drap
de lit qui se soulève et on voit ce
qu'il ya ce qui a eu chaud sur le lit
mais qui a beaucoup de mal dans
l'application après ça vient uniquement
de st or le cinéma qui a une vision
directe muet au parlant tu permets de
huy de voir tout de sentir et de juger
tout de suite
vous passionner pour l'économie depuis
longtemps où ses récents
mais c'est bon c'est mon métier mon
travail je ne vois pas comme un film se
ferait sans dépenser ou deux mais je
pense que vous élargissez votre champ et
que vous mais ce que vous ne devez pas
vous intéresser au point par exemple
vous pourriez donner des conseils
d'économie ou de finance à monsieur
balladur à monsieur van der i am sulky
sarkozy monsieur enfants déry
certainement mais
mais il n'en veut pas oui mais n'en
veulent pas moi je peux leur dire chaque
fois que quand le dollar va baisser
quand le dollar va monter pour leur dire
avant tout à fait ah oui chaque fois que
balladur tend la main le dollar est bas
et chaque fois que il pris vers
l'amérique le dollar et aux dons qui a
qu'à regarder quand ce qui il demande
quelque chose à l'amérique et quand ce
qui fait le mendiant quels sont les deux
attitudes
tout à fait et comme ils font tous
pareil en europe 1 on serait tout de
suite ah bon alors donc vous pouvez
spéculer à avec efficacité oui mais je
tiens pas à m'enrichir
très bien le quand même et ce qui doit
rester quand même depuis le début de
votre vie notre occupation dominante
c'est quand même la lecture c'est les
livres le romanesque en romanès les
romances qu'il me sens bien que vous
avez dû déclarer quelque part que quand
vous étiez jeune homme votre ambition
était de publier un roman chez gallimard
oui ça c'était là c'est l éducation qu
un vrai j'admirais astruc et rohmer même
qu'il avait fait mais le romanesque le
cinéma par mail romanesque du monde que
ne permet pas le roman et permet de
recevoir dans des clairement il faut
donner et
est bon les deux les deux vont s'en faut
vraiment inventé dans le roman je
relisais léviathan qui vient de julien
green le bluesy aujourd'hui oui
effectivement c'est inadapté on peut pas
faire autrement on peut pas inventé ça
parce que le monde vous est donné au
cinéma vous lisiez léviathan tout
simplement pas c'est un plaisir de
relire ce luth et surtout la chance de
mieux ou bien ou ce que vous aviez
l'idée lui est ce que je peux peut-être
m'ont inspiré pour un an lors je me dit
l'élu dans mon adolescence dans sa base
est
complètement bouleversée de découvrir
qu'un monde romanesque existait comme ça
et je voulais revoir ciselé je lis
retrouver cinq autres totalement
complètement paraît donc vous avez
retrouvé le jeune homme qui lisait avec
ce plaisir vous avez de la veine que les
terminer à vendredi oui parce que très
bon ça y est parvenu
mais alors comment comment faites vous
allez souvent la librairie vous acheter
des livres
oui c'est très réconfortant mais gilles
souvent lit les titres seulement parce
qu'on peut pas et il y en a trop toutes
les citations qui sont dans les classes
pour moi et dans beaucoup d'autres de
vos films trouvent que vous lisez les
vivres mais au moment oui mais au moment
mais je respire des fleurs ou si je
prends de la pluie et puis ça c'est dans
les films oui mais une situation folle à
noter quelque part vous le voulez vous
là bas au moment faire un film si elle
est en correspondance à quelque chose
effectivement elle faillit par télé vous
avez une grande bibliothèque ou non tout
petit le petit mais qu'est ce qu'on fait
de tous les livres que vous achetez
alors le jeu d'après vous les jeter mais
je t'ai oui y avait toutes les
références
ou mais j'ai juste pris celle qui qui
pouvait m'être utile bon
je suis étonné que vous utilisez janvier
mai
il fait pas la place bah oui mais quand
même pourquoi pas la place je vous ai
vue là la place quand même toutes vos
machines mais beaucoup de places bah oui
mais c'est déjà ça c'est votre métier
enfin la lecture c'est quand même votre
passion non pas c'est ce que disait
valéry larbaud mais plus que ça ce vice
impuni la lecture ou bien beau de leers
hypocrite lecteurs nous semble à mon
frère
mais oui et fait tout à fait mais c'est
différent il faut il faut y aller et il
vous reçoit le cinéma c'est il vient
vers vous où le monde vit à travers lui
et vous êtes là c'est la même chose
c'est ce que j'appelle le roman le
romanesque l'un est plus scientifique
l'autre plus romanesque
mais vous êtes plutôt un lecteur qui
retrouve effectivement des livres aux
presses toujours les mêmes je l'aimais
mais vous n'allez pas la découverte de
nouveaux auteurs
je les fais quand j'étais jeune et
si vous voulez de homer
à proust pas mal c'est pas mal même si
vous avez tous lu c'est non
après on peut plus oui on peut plus lire
les nouveaux biens alors jean-luc godard
nous allons inaugurer ensemble une
rubrique qui reviendra assez
régulièrement dans cette émission c'est
d'études ma préférence à moi dans
laquelle en fin d'émission je recevrai
des débutants talentueux que ce soit des
romanciers essayistes des metteurs en
scène ou des comédiens et je vais
remercier julien clerc pour m'avoir
autorisé à utiliser
alors j'ai donc le plaisir d'accueillir
agnès desarthe d'agnès desarthe alors je
vais vous la présentez vous avez 27 ans
elle a 27 ans donc elle est normalienne
elle est agrégée de linguistique vous
enseignez traduisez l'anglais vous êtes
l'auteur d'une dizaine de livres pour
enfants est d'ailleurs le dernier doit
si c'est la femme du bouc émissaire
c'est un titre d'ailleurs j'ai pas lu
moi j'ai vu celui-ci met à temps complet
mais je trouve ça c'est à deschamps
c'est de publier à l'école des loisirs
alors est ce que tous ces livres que
vous avez fait pour les enfants c'était
des galops d'entraînement pour écrire un
vrai premier livre non pas du tout pas
de faim je vois pas en quoi celui-là est
plus vrai que les autres qui sont tous
en carton et ou bien ils sont c'est un
vrai livre aussi enfin je veux dire
celui vous avez montré la femme du
bouc-émissaire moi j'ai pas pensé je
vais commencer par faire des livres pour
enfants parce que je suis pas très forte
alors ça c'est un peu nul alors je vais
bien y arriver et c est après quand je
serai vraiment ford ferait un truc pour
les grands noms j'ai fait des livres
pour enfants puisque ça s'est trouvé
comme ça
je sais pas j'avais envie d'écrire et
puis on m'a dit tiens écrit un livre
pour enfants je les fais parce que c'est
souvent celle inverse souvent des gens
écrivent d'abord aux adultes puis
deviennent célèbres la prise écrit pour
les enfants
non je n'ai pas quoi avez vous écrit
d'abord pour lui c'est con parce qu'on
me l'a dit parce qu'on m'a demandé moi
je fais toujours très gentiment ce qu'on
me demande avec the dirt cheap non mais
je voulais écrire on me dit farid pour
enfants j'ai essayé puis ça m'a plu
alors j'ai continué et puis je pensais
pas j'en ai fait un deux trois et puis
ça continue et puis je m'étais je me
disais pas à et quand je ferai enfin
monique pour adieu là ça va être génial
je pensais pas du tout alors donc il est
là il existe il publie aux éditions de
l'olivier et cette étude quelques
minutes de bonheur absolu quelques
minutes de bonheur absolu alors c'est
une histoire de deux sages-femmes qui a
lot d'abord justement comme c'est
vraiment une histoire de sages-femmes et
si bons qu'ils racontent qu'ils aient
mal dans sa peau mais revenir mais vous
l'avez raconté à la troisième personne
je sais que beaucoup de romans c'est
quand il commence il dit est ce que je
vais écrire la première personne pour la
troisième personne est ce que vous êtes
posé ce problème
oui c'est un problème technique ce qui
était bien dans le fait d'avoir écrit
des livres pour enfants c'est tout
simplement j'avais des livres avant
qu'il soit pour enfants ou pas j'avais
écrit donc j'avais travaillé donc moi
j'ai plein de problèmes techniques des
problèmes avec les temps des verbes sont
très compliqués je trouve en français et
je m'en sors pas et à la première
personne c'est compliqué le passé simple
qui ressemble au passé à l'imparfait
enfin ça me poser des problèmes donc je
me suis dit première personne
ça me bloque donc je reviens de 3m stc
pas hésité très longtemps oui donc
vraiment ils sont faits la troisième
personne et non annoncé
bon alors est-ce que c'est plus comme ça
raconte l'histoire d'une sage-femme
l'impression dès que vous avez passé
votre temps dans les maternités
tellement vous êtes alors non je ne suis
pas sage pas moi même oui je sais ça je
le vivais aucune sache annonceurs pour
être un hobby
de bise
non non en fait j'ai passé six jours
dans une clinique d'accouchement comme
la plupart des femmes qui ont eu des
bébés en dans les pays où ça s'est fait
comme ça on va là fini et puis voilà et
puis et puis j'ai vu j'ai pas quelques
sages femmes parce qu'elles n'y a un
déroulement
c'est tout je vais pas passer ma vie
dans les landes dont vous avez un enfant
puisque le dire est ce qu'elle est là qu
est ce qu on peut faire une comparaison
entre l'accouchement et d'un livre et
l'accouchement de d'un enfant qui
viennent
pas du tout c'est bien beau alors le
revenant de pose une question sérieuse
votre personnage s'appelle cyril c'est
une femme c'est une femme qui est
curieux c'est que on a l'impression
qu'elle ferait tout pour être heureuse
mais il y a comme un refus d'où vient ce
refus
c'est pas vraiment un refus moi je crois
pas qu'elle refuse d'être heureuse parce
que là une fille qui a tout pour être
heureuse et qui refuse c'est une chieuse
quoi y'a pas d'autres moi et moi pour
moi c'est pas ça ce personnage les pins
peut vous pour vous peut-être pour moi
non alors pour moi c'est pas cela c'est
juste une une fille qui a tout pour être
heureuse on sais pas moi je donne les
éléments que je donne mais bon c'est un
personnage ya sûrement d'autres choses
et puis en fait c'est pas qu'elle refuse
d'être heureuse elle se dit pas
malheureuse elles sont juste qu'il ya
des choses qu'elle n'arrive pas à faire
mais c'est simplement parce qu'elle
traîne un boulet en quoi mais je pense
pas que ce soit un refus je pense que
c'est peut-être dans son cas une juste
une incapacité qu'on a l'impression de
n'être jamais la hauteur ouais mais
parce que je crois qu'elle est qu'il ya
un problème d'âge dans ce livre moi j'ai
choisi un est lâché plus qu'à l'âge mais
enfin à peu près 25 ans et j'avais
choisi cet âge là parce que j'avais
l'impression que c'était un âge où on
pouvait sentir complètement tirée en
arrière par son enfance et où effrayé
par ce qui allait arriver parce qu'on
voyait arriver et par tous les possibles
qui se ferment les uns après les autres
et donc il ya des moments où on peut
avoir la capacité d'être heureux parce
qu'on a le souvenir de bonheur tellement
intense quand on est petit par exemple
que l'idée de bonheur à ces moyens de
l'âge adulte peuvent paraître
complètement dégradée par rapport donc
je pense que c'est plutôt ça pour moi
qui se manifeste pas ce qu'est la même
peur des gens qu'elle aime c'est ça qui
est dit qu'il était en déplacement oui
c'est certain moment elle se pose ces
questions dit est ce que je n'ai pas
peur des gens que j'aime voyez une scène
qui formidable danse olivia plusieurs
rues godard a lorsqu'il est celle qui
donne d'ailleurs son titre s'est elle se
rappelle des souvenirs d'enfance et l
aide elle se cache la jeune fille cyril
se se cache dans une armoire et elle se
dit qu'après ma mère ma petite soeur ils
vont passer et je vais entendre qu'elles
vont dire alors elle est où tu vois ce
une joueur formidable elle se dit je
vais vivre des minutes de bonheur absolu
et alors là c'est la petite sûr parce
qu'à ce moment là elle dit ben non je me
fais ma petite copine et puis là mais
revient et elle part elle reste seule
dans le placard il ne s'est rien passé
c'est une scène superbe
vous tombez pas absolument super et on
va s'en servir c'est une scène qui m'a
si je les ai écrites et parce qu'elle me
touchait et puis que et puis je trouvais
que c'était peut-être a posteriori après
parce que moi quand je les écris tu
chies j'y pensais pas spécialement et
puis médias servier partie par exemple
des scènes que j'aurais pu enlever et
puis après 8 heures oui ben oui c'est ce
dont je me suis rendu compte parce que
des gens qui lisait le libre disait
années cette scène oui cette scène etc
et puis quand je suis tombé la phrase je
sais pas si vous vous souvenez la phrase
d'exergue en fait tu fais référence
cette phrase puisque c'est la phrase de
winnicott se cache et un plaisir mais ne
pas être trouvée est une catastrophe
et quand je suis tombé sur cette fois je
me suis rendu compte que c'était en fait
ça que j'avais voulu raconter c'est une
fois google à ce que tu une fois ce
qu'on ne te riex à
se cacher est un plaisir ne pas être
tombé d'une catastrophe tout à fait ça
on peut en faire une scène comme
mademoiselle la fête où tout un film au
tout un roman tout à fait la jeune fille
tout à fait vous pourriez partir de ça
non seulement pour n en le doigt
oui c'est à dire moi j'avais
l'impression que ça peut être ses
emblématiques de plein de choses savez
on sent que j'ai pas on est tous on est
tous caché en attendant d'être découvert
ne sais pas par qui on ne sait pas
exactement par quoi en même temps on a
peur d'être découvert enfin bcc pour
plein de choses c'est comme ça ce qui
est si bien dans votre roman c'est pour
ça que j'ai choisi c'est qu'il ya un ton
assez nerveux après c'est ironique même
et vous avez je trouve moi l'art du
dialogue fait de très très beaux
dialogues et voilà c'est pourquoi j'ai
trouvé j'ai pris beaucoup plus d'intérêt
à lire cet ouvrage qui n'est pas qui est
un ouvrage d'ailleurs très exigeant très
très ambitieux pour pour un premier
roman
ne vous racontez pas une petite histoire
comme ça à l'eau de rose et est ce que
malheureusement donc jean luc godard
vous a pas lu ce qui est dommage mais il
y pas les jeunes romanciers ne le velly
julien green qui à 90 ans cette année
quand vous aurez 90 ans jean luc godard
vous l'iran
et il ya une chose quand même c'est que
n'êtes vous pas mariée à un cinéaste 6 à
agnès desarthe et maria cinéaste qui a
fait céder film ou pas oui il ya fait
des filles j'ai fait des films courts
donc c'est pour ça que y'a pas son va
tout sur des actifs c'est lui qui aime
tant la tournée son premier long métrage
la main oui le qui s'appelle comment
dante de sa bande de sa wii donc c'est
pas facile à prononcer la danseuse
d'habitude j'arrive bien mais là je sais
pas ce que j'ai dans deux ans qu'il va
passer alors là oui il va faire de son
premier depuis son premier long métrage
face il a fait des films et des cours
dont qui sont pas passés passagers
collaborer ou pas sur les premiers
j'avais collaboré vous suffisait la
cuisine et puis les impôts les scénarios
mais maintenant il ya trop de monde à
nourrir alors je peux pas puis avec les
enfants j'ai plus de temps oui donc
jeudi il me donne
je lis ces scénarios mais moi j'ai du
mal à jean luc godard vous recevez des
lettres du cinéaste qui veulent
commencer qui vous envoie d'aider des
textes en disant est ce que je pensais
que je pourrais tourner ça où passe un
peu comme ça
ils montrent en général
si j'ai l'occasion de leur
répondre moi je me sens pas du tout
obligé de répondre et quand j'en vois je
le redis essayer de vous pouvez
aujourd'hui ce qu'on ne pouvait pas
l'époque avec les
les petites caméras japonaise etc
vous quelques copains ou votre absence
de copains où vous tout seul vous pouvez
faire des films si vous voulez si vous
voulez tout de suite faire hollywood
vous ne pouvez pas vous de choisir en
général ils veulent en tout de suite
faire hollywood si oui mais quand ils
vous ont entendu tout à leur dire le
cinéma bon finalement il est mort c'est
pas très réjouissant pour les jeunes ont
une idée du cinéma qui existait même une
idée de l'art enfin comme ça ça c'est
autre chose je veux dire la lan une idée
de la langue les romans ou si tous je
veux dire on va vers la
la langue informe informatique si vous
voulez qui n'est plus la langue
grammaticales sur le papier qui change
en qui a qui amènera certainement des
choses mais on est dans une époque de
deux crevaisons mais à 10 de ça quand on
écrit un roman quand on fait ses débuts
devant c est ce qu'on se dit pas mais à
quoi ça sert est-ce que pourquoi ajouté
un roman à ces milliers à ces dizaines
de milliers à ces chefs-d'oeuvre qui
existe est ce que non enfin si sûrement
des peut-être enfin je peux pas répondre
pour les gens jeunes votre moi je me
pose pas cette question je fais ce que
j'ai envie ce qui est une chance
incroyable d'ailleurs mais moi quand je
vois justement les grands enfin rien ne
me donne plus envie d'écrire que de lire
un roman que j'adore et que je trouve
incroyablement beau et incroyablement
inatteignable samon ça me donne envie
d'écrire alors je le fais normal si on a
envie de créer un rapport question les
romanciers qui vous a donné envie
d'écrire des romans
le premier ça devait être salinger je
crois parce que tu es le seul que
j'arrivais à lire j'ai lu très très tard
je n'arrivais pas à lire ça m'ennuyait
mais lui j'aimais bien lire ces lieux et
puis après après il ya eu faute n'est
il pas mal d'américains en fait
et et puis il ya eu à oui il y avait
aussi chez les brèches et puis j'ai pas
contre la littérature américaine c'est
maintenant si je l'étais pas je disais
pas américains au sens de ce qui avait
été dit précédemment par rapport au
cinéma américain pas du tout c'était
juste parce qu'ils se trouvent et qui la
faisait déjà deux américains que le
troisième temps que mais c'est un
américain taku je me suis souvenu de
gustave flaubert dossier pas je viens
grille
j'ai pas beaucoup de culture je n'ai pas
dû décider ça me manque alors
dans le film que j'ai eu le plaisir de
voir chez vous jean luc godard qui
s'intitule un essai d'investigation
cinématographique sur la russie c'est un
film inédit de 50 minutes qui est une
sorte de représentation à la fois
historiques poétique que
culturel
admirable de la russie pas à travers des
montages des décollages à travers des
références des citations de films de
deux romans russes et ses terrasses est
absolument remarquable est-ce qu'on
verra un jour ce fait je ne pense pas
non
il appartient un producteur de de ce
pays dont les habitants n'ont pas non
ces prix et là je crois que le
producteur en plus pouvoir alors si on
ne voit pas que d'y aller aux élections
on voit pas qu'on voit au moins une
minute qu'on envoie une minute s'il vous
plaît s'il vous plaît une minute de ce
film le première fois
voilà ce que j'ai dit vous faites ce que
vous voulez moi je n'irai pas avec
hitler et napoléon tous les gens
intelligents profit de la situation de
cette pauvre russie pour l'envahir
encore une fois
pourquoi est ce que l'occident veut
encore envahi ce pays
c'est simple parce que c'est la patrie
de la fiction et que l'occident ne sait
plus quoi apporter
je viens encore dit cela si vous allez à
l'hôtel raphaël je suis certain que le
mortier ressemble vincent
que les servantes dans les chambres
ressemblent aux deux soeurs et si vous
voyez une femme seule dans la salle à
manger de l'avenue kléber où qui
signèrent mis quatre ans à signer avec
les vietnamiens
soyez certains que cette femme
ressemblera comme une soeur elle aussi à
la karénine
voilà c'est les enfants jouaient la
russie très très bonne j'espère que je
le vire à bord il ya un certain moment
vous prochain invité de c donc alexandre
soljenitsyne semaine prochaine un moment
vous vous citez l'archipel du goulag et
vous fait remarquer six fois vous le dit
qu' il s'agit d'un essai d'investigation
littéraire absolument donc quoi ça vous
à face à choquer ou pas de ce sous titre
n'ont même pas du tout c'est mon métier
de cinéaste de faire remarquer ce que ce
que les gens ou de de redécouvrir ce que
les gens ont recouvert c'est assez
étrange et magnifique un livre
du poids de l'archipel du goulag le zéro
et l'infini ne s'appelait pas ne
s'appelait pas comme ça là il sans fin
il était sous titré ce qui pour moi est
le vrai titre car c'est la légende et
celle investigations
littéraire avec une question à poser
alexandre soljenitsyne à ses proches
pour la semaine prochaine eh ben vous
lui demandez si souvient que
d'avoir un petit archipel du goulag
ainsi quel est le vrai titre de
l'archipel du goulag et pourquoi il
appelle ainsi ben je pense parce que
c'était vraiment ça un essai
d'investigation comme c'est pas une
question ça et pas un pamphlet politique
c'est la fin de l'émission le
questionnaire votre mot préféré jean luc
godard
chocques smooth pardon
shuck smooth shox nz ça veut dire quoi
anne-marie
le mot vous détestez
ministre de l'intérieur votre drogue
favorite
leur romanesque le son le bruit que vous
aimez
la pluie sur par an dans les arbres et
le son le bruit que vous détestez
les couinements du fax
autres joueront gros mot blasphème
favori
excusez moi j'en ai aucun
suisse ne jure pas
un mou femmes pour illustrer un nouveau
billet de banque
adolf hitler
métier que vous n'auriez pas aimé faire
ministre de l'intérieur
laplante l'arbre l'animal dans lequel
vous aimeriez être réincarné
cauchemar
est enfin si dieu existe on y revient si
dieu existe qu aimeriez vous après votre
mort l'entendre vous dire à vous jean
luc godard
c'est pas trop tôt mettez-vous là
bien
présente et je fais que cadeaux faut
être venue de quelques ouvrages je peux
vous les avez vous hésité valery larbaud
tout à l'heure de la réédition la
collection imaginée gagne 1,2 à mort
heureusement avec toi vous connaissez et
cerner le symposium enfin ça c'est le
aimé de jacques rivière qui par la même
collection non mais j'en prends quand
les autres sont placés sainte-beuve les
portraits du théâtre samedi c'est
trouvant il s'est souvent trompé sur ses
contemporains mais quand il parle des
écrivains qui l'ont précédé c'est pas
mal du tout c'est la collection bouquins
cd portrait littéraire de personnes
peuvent alors si ceux ci c'est le gilles
deleuze de laver lui c'est des essais
littéraires des deux sur bas sur beckett
via sur nietzsche sur amazon sur platon
et ses critiques et cliniques et un
certain moment il dit que veut dire jean
luc godard quant aux noms du cinéma ils
affirment qu'entre un travelling un
panoramique il y a un problème moral
vous l'avez lu solide pack nom d'
appâter moi ça me fait trop mal je vous
signale bâle weil a ordonné sa michel
cassé du vide à la création c'est un
astrophysicien
voulais pas le lire non d'accord très
bien je vous proposais ceci aussi c'est
la pensée économique depuis keynes c'est
tous les économistes qui sont illustrés
dans la dans l'économie par michel baud
et de salaire sur aux éditions du seuil
parmi une grande de ti sur maurice
allais surtout ces deux là est d'accord
il qu'on descende prendra et puis alors
celui là vous me l'avez recommandé enfin
vous m'avez dit fred lire c'est moi
c'est peter drucker au delà du
capitalisme aux éditions dunod vous avez
donc lieu mais je parle de l'est
puisqu'il avait dû tuer et c'est un
ouvrage intéressant
pour connaître la la pensée des
puissants d'aujourd'hui oui très bien et
puis là je vous signale que si vous
voulez il ya des godard pouvez vous les
procurer g0 lui avant de venir goda par
jean-luc groupe doit par exemple marie
lemarque série suez l'eau et d'autres il
ya les cahiers du cinéma et puis surtout
le jean luc godard par jean luc godard
aux éditions des cahiers du cinéma voilà
j'en ai fini merci
la semaine prochaine donc horaires
exceptionnels attention horaire
exceptionnel l'émission commence à 20h50
pourquoi eh bien
bien grâce à alexandre soljenitsyne qui
est un homme immense du 20e siècle merci
jean luc godard merci merci à tous merci
aux téléspectateurs et merci à tous
[Musique]